i Samuel lives here and in this video
you're going to learn about rent to rent
deals if you're just gonna learn about
rent amend deals you're gonna see me
clinch our enter and deal and you're
gonna go inside one on this video so
stay tuned okay so I'm here driving on
my way to meet a rent to rent
perspective landlord we've pretty much
sealed the deal over the phone but now
I'm driving to their house all the way
in Kidderminster and hopefully it'll be
a little bit less of a wasted trip as my
last video in Manchester I here with
Amanda Amanda hey so here's the
situation we're gonna hopefully get the
keys signed the paperwork when we get
there and once we've done that we're
gonna go and check out the house
so we're here sat down on the sofa about
to collect the rent to rent keys the
beautiful lady Sarah he's got a great
voice but hasn't got a makeup on so
doesn't want to be on the camera
explaining why she's passed this to us
on a bed to many pastors honest - I went
to rent you're looking for a guaranteed
and you don't mind whether you you're
not necessarily looking to make a load
of money you'd rather a smaller amount
of memory which is fixed then a lot
which isn't fixed is that right yeah
peace of mind so she is beautiful
despite your not being able to see a
face so uh great that's other keys
boom well there's a lot of keys for just
want Oh what is this we're gonna have
fun go over the house now and we Monday
yeah right Sarah good to see you
we've got the keys we got the contract
signed let's go have a look at the house
so I'm really looking forward to seeing
the house sarah said that she doesn't
want the hassle all the responsibility
of the property but the thing is we're
gonna be passing it over to a really
good management company anyway so
there's very very little for us gonna
have to do as a renter enter our options
are we can either keep the property and
make a gross profit of five hundred
pounds per month to be a little bit less
than that once we've outsourced
everything but still for nothing up
front and practically no work just a
quick drive to Kidderminster that's not
bad
the other option would be that we pass
their intimate deal on to somebody and
make it quick four or five thousand
pound fee but then we've not let any
passive income see Monday you'd rather
do the quick pass it on have a baby
wouldn't even use them when it's gone
holiday whereas I'm all about passive
income so
we'll find out when we get there or judo
would you rather make 500 pounds a month
for passive income or make a quick 5
grand let us know comment below when
you've investing nothing that's not
really that bad or you think you moment
yeah you're you'd rather pass it on for
you wouldn't ya yeah I just get a quick
5 grand
rather than have it on our portfolio oh
I'm not sure you know what when you're
creative the world is your oyster you
can make so much money in property
without starting with anyway
[Music]
oh yeah it's on the back side
there's no TV or anything but the sofas
are good this is what used to be
decorated recently to a decent standard
good I'm praying that the kitchen looks
good so no one's seen this yet let's see
what it looks like oh nice very good
[Music]
what do you reckon
obviously this is a new kitchen new
boiler very good this is just gone in a
couple of months ago they've clearly
done this up to rents out but just what
a guarantee rats nice
this will win our dream this assuming
the bedrooms are good this or in a dream
yeah
also it's really close I mean you could
probably probably walk to the center in
about seven to ten minutes
terminate Center it's nice but down is
there a big move to begin with that so
this is nice it's a small double room
how do you know if it's a double room or
a single room or size it's after be all
the easy way is if it's got a double bed
there it's a double room so this is a
dorm room and they've furnished this
exactly as they should exactly as we
furnish it ready for you to go
downstairs we've got a nice bathroom
communal bathroom you know kitchen nice
lounge we've got one double room so I'm
hoping for three good rooms upstairs
yeah why'd you stay here a little bit
just think about life so we're talking
three doubles so far we've got a little
built-in wardrobe we've got a wardrobe
chest tools bed this is great okay so
it's not a big room but it is a room
let's have a little measurement you got
your tech news remember geez okay
possibly in your dashboard look I pause
there if I haven't got one I failed
there's a property investor lots of my
CDs oh yes come on and that's because
I'm a professional so it is 10 10 by y66
there's 10 10 while 6 6 should be just
about okay now listen if you can fit a
bed just the drawers and a wardrobe in
it like this it will rent out all day
long however if it's less than 70
squared foot and the council look into
it change the rules or anything you just
want to make sure that if you can it's
70 squared foot as a minimum so how you
can do that is we can go on to just
Google square foot calculator and here
we go so it is ten ten by six foot six
which gives us a total of seventy point
four so where we are okay so this room
is plenty big enough so we've got one
single we've got three very large
doubles we've got a communal kitchen and
communal lounge and then communal
bathroom so we should easy to get for
this property 1,400 pounds I think it
would rent out like that for 1,400
pounds it's furnished yet we haven't got
to spend a penny on it which is me and
1,400 - 550 pounds to go to Sarah which
is gonna give 850 - 300 pounds for the
bells and when it costs I've got a lot
of HMOs so I know how much they cost
them in this kind of area 300 pounds
very realistic
leaves us with 550 pounds per month now
off that 550 pounds we're gonna need to
pay somebody to manage it and look after
it so I think realistically we'll
probably be left and maybe 250 pounds on
management and maintenance all I think
you're talking 300 pounds a month profit
after paying everybody without having to
touch it so not bad
what do you think Amanda I really like
it I think it's a great house I love the
big double rooms I think we should go
back to this one and you saw we're going
to keep passing on it is nice and this
would read out like a dream dear because
you've been involved in hmmm management
I mean what are your thoughts on the
area I understand why Sarah has passed
it on because she doesn't want any
hassle whatsoever but do you think that
we've got a pretty steal yeah yeah I
think so I think so so in conclusion no
money down deals are possible you don't
need money to make money in property you
can do rent to rent lease option
agreement sourcing but this is a
real-life live example of a rent to rent
deal that we've just secured today
hopefully that's been helpful and useful
also another tip is always bring a tape
measure wherever you go so if you like
to watch more videos like that don't
forget subscribe right now below and I
look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]